hey everybody Welcome to Leed live today
we're going to talk about a topic that's
on a lot of people's lips the church and
the
state um welcome Samuel yes hello it's
good to be here Mr Samuel Tucker is a
evangelist has a YouTube page and a
YouTube channel that he and his wife
actually teach on a lot of these things
and this is a a topic that we're
starting to see obviously we're seeing a
lot of political things in the newsed
and and now there's a lot of talk going
we need God back into this world we need
God back into our into our um State and
how how do we respond to that is this a
good thing is this something we should
be you know champing or there's some
cautionary things that we should be
careful of yeah no it's it's a very good
point you know and I'm pretty sure we're
all familiar with the verse in a pro
vers CH 14 where it says that
righteousness exalteth a nation but sin
is a reproach to any people so the
importance of having right principle in
a state in a government is essential but
it really is determined upon how that is
implemented and so especially for us as
Christians I mean it's it's one thing
when you're talking about people who
don't understand biblical principles but
when you're talking about those of us as
Christians we know that the Reformation
of an individual begins in the heart you
know and this is part of the reason why
and we'll get into it you know a little
bit why when Jesus was trying to
inculate right principle with the Jewish
nation and you know when he was on the
earth you know he didn't go down to
Augustus Caesar you know he didn't go
down to Pontius pilot in order to try to
get them to enact legislation to make
the Jewish Nation spiritual you know he
started with proper Revival and
reformation and so that's where we have
to start that's actually a really good
point I haven't really thought about
that but yeah if you just observe
Jesus's life he wasn't like you know
advocating in the political circles yeah
he interacted with them but you know it
was it was through that personal
interaction yeah um you know and it's
and it's and it's a it's sort of a
delicate balance because I I really do
uh I I mean I want people to have an
understanding of Jesus indeed and you
know we've left it out of the schools
look at where our world has been because
we've basically forgotten you know God
in the equation and so now people are
calling for that back but how could this
be a bad thing no exactly and I know
especially in this day and age you know
in Western Society in general you know
as Christians you know whatever you know
religious persuasion of of Christianity
that you know you're affiliated with I
mean you see the degradation of morals
just in general and it can be very um
startling you know obviously it's very
eye openening and the and the genuine
question is how do we get morality back
into society properly but again if we're
going to do that we have to use the
methods and principles that Jesus used
because as we're going to find out you
know in in some of these sessions that
there's a right way to do this and
there's a very satanic way to try to
attempt it that actually just encourages
more Satanism you know and so yeah this
is going to be interesting for sure yeah
awesome well let's dive into it no
indeed indeed so as you can see here is
a church and state so in order to give
like a foundation of this it's really
important to have a historical backdrop
and especially you know as as a young
Christian you know we're all relatively
young um one of the subjects that um is
hated the most is history and
unfortunately uh This lends to a lot of
deception uh we know even in Matthew 24
the very first thing that Jesus warned
against was deception right when they're
asking him about like you know how do we
get to to Heaven here and that's the
first thing that he says exactly you
know one of the main reasons and it's
amazing when you look through the
history of the Old Testament why the
Jews kept falling into apostasy is
because they forgot their history even
when you look in the Book of Judges you
know when the Bible says that the
children of isual they serve uh God all
the days of Joshua and all of the elders
that outlived Joshua but unfortunately
when that generation arose because they
didn't understand the history you know
exactly yes so let's uh get into it so
as you can see on the screen here what
we're going to do we're going to um go
through a little subject called the
trial of Rome uh the there are very
serious parallels between the Roman
Empire and the current Empire of the
United States you know the United States
was established as a constitutional
republic but we're no longer a republic
we're really an Empire uh and so this is
very interesting so you can see here
this is an you know AI generated picture
of of ancient Rome and then in the
distance you can see an American flag I
mean and even when you look go to
Washington DC you see all of the Roman
iconography and you know that's not by
accident it's not by accident
all right so going through it on the
screen this is a gent by the name of PT
McAn he was a very brilliant uh
Christian educator in the uh turn of the
20th century had a lot of uh major
influence notice what he said about the
beginning of uh the United States we're
getting to a point it says among the
great nations of ancient times the
Republic of Rome is at once the most
gigantic and striking figure in the
history of mankind it says only two
republics have ever risen to a pitch of
grandeur and prominence sufficient to
entitle them to a rank in the galaxy of
the great world power so again
emphasizing the point you have the Roman
Empire and you have the United States
now we know that the Roman Empire is no
longer in existence and so the question
is what led to the degradation of the
Roman Empire now remember we're talking
about church and state church and state
all right here this is a John by the
name of Chris henes he talks about
unfortunately lot of the degradation of
the United States uh very interesting
point he says the US government
subservient to corporate power has
become a burlesque in in the middle he
says the bloated military sunking the
marrow out of the nation is unsalable so
that's one point one of the things that
led to the degradation of ancient Rome
was that they were unnecessarily
expanding their military and
unfortunately as the United States we do
the same thing for point of
clarification what do you mean by that
the United States is expanding uh
because we know that they're actually
struggling to recruit at this point no
yeah so um you know we made the
statement that the United States is an
Empire now I don't know if our audience
is are familiar and this is again you
know a lot of us as Americans not being
educated on this is that uh we as the
United States spend roughly around a
trillion dollars on so-called defense
every year right you know the major you
know um weapons manufacturers Boeing
locki Martin Ron all of these uh
countries we have almost a thousand
military bases around the world and so
the question is if we're supposed to be
a democracy Republic all of these things
why are we so outstretched why do we
have CIA black sites why do we have
Guantanamo Bay and all these things and
so unfortunately this is how Empires run
and function now now true it is very
true that um there there are issues with
recruitment you know I was even looking
at an article that uh the United States
government was saying that um the you
know overweight population of the United
States is actually a national security
threat um and it's a national security
threat because there's not enough uh
able-bodied persons to enter the
military wow so that is true but you
know with the United States when you
have you know access you know to F35
fighter jets and you have atomic bombs
certainly having Personnel is important
but when you can just bomb everything I
mean it's you know it's pretty crazy
that we have that amount of money being
expended to basically police or monitor
or whatever like have dominance over the
world when I think I remember looking up
years ago like what it would take to
solve world hunger and it was like in
the hundreds of Millions like we were
spending more on our our our our
military when we could just like help
the whole world but exactly it's
unfortunate yeah so that's one point
it's a very good question so this is
another point this is a symbol of
something called bread and circus I
don't know if if we're familiar with
that concept so as I'm pretty sure you
all talked about to some degree ancient
Rome uh the hierarchy started to
manipulate the common people and in
order to distract them they had the
Coliseum games but uh that's not the
point of this so we're not going to
spend too much time on it just talking
about some of y roome fell uh this is a
man by the name of ettien de la he was a
French politician uh during the 16
Century notice what he said plays farces
spectacles Gladiators strange beasts
Meadows pictures and other such opiates
these were for ancient be peoples the
bait towards slavery and the price of
their Liberty the instruments of
tyranny and so a lot of times people
will say well you know religion is the
opiate of the masses but it's really
These Foolish entertainments yeah true
that all they care about is cheap food
and entertainment exactly exactly so
again modern day parallel we have the
Super Bowl here and again you know I
grew up watching all of these things and
it's amazing how we're conditioned to
believe that all of the billions of
dollars that are generated from these
mechanisms is purely left up to chance
you know you just don't make money that
way MH all right skipping past this this
article talks about how the US
government literally subsidizes um all
of these football stadiums to keep us
sedated it's crazy
from the guardian all right getting to
another point it says this is from NBC
talking about Black Panther you know
more entertainments why does a white CIA
agent play the hero to Killer's V
villain in the Black Panther so many of
these superhero movies the United States
is always the Savior always a savior MH
Point all right this is the this is one
of the main thrusts so what greatly led
to the degradation of the Roman Empire
was the fusion of church and state and
so again we're talking about this
concept it's important to understand the
history so this is a gentleman on the
screen by the name of a Jones very
brilliant Christian um Theologian and
educator this is from a book that he
wrote uh this says this word Antipas is
not a person's name but is a term
characteristic of the times now for our
audience that are listening when he's
talking about Antipas when you read
about the seven churches in the Book of
Revelation um one of those uh the
churches during that time period this
word anpus was used and at Jones Goes on
to explain that this anpus is not
talking about an actual person but
actual actually the rise of the Roman
Catholic institution and so he goes
through a lot of that history and so it
says therefore the word anpus against
this is at the bottom against P or Papa
shows the growth of the papacy in the
period immediately following
a13 so uh during that uh time period of
the churches it talks about there will
be persecution 10 days talking about the
10 years persecution of the emperor
Diocesan it's a lot of history it says
this was the period of Constantine and
onward in which the papacy itself was
distinctly formed so I believe we get
somewhat of an understanding as to what
was happening so this is where they
really started to gain power this is
where they started to gain power during
the reign of Constantine so what we're
going to seek to do before this segment
is over is go into some of this history
and see how this church and state
concept really got its birth and its
incipiency
all right it says this is from uh his
book ecclesiastical Empire it says the
immediate effect of this apostasy again
so the Christian church and the Roman
Empire fusing together which developed
the papacy in the Roman Empire was the
complete ruin of the Roman Empire now
even as we continue one of the great
reasons why the concept of church and
state from an Earthly standpoint is
wrong is because you have two uh as it
were opposing um IDE Oles so now they're
both right in their proper place you
have morality you know the the church
and you have civility which is the state
now intrinsically the concept of church
and state is not bad because that's how
God actually runs his Universe because
the god of Heaven it's literally a
fusion of church and state there's a
government exactly in fact that's what
Lucifer was trying to take over was to
reform the government exactly to reform
the government now Jesus said you know
very interesting statement in his Sermon
on the Mount you know thy will be done
in earth as it is in heaven so God has
tried to reproduce his theocracy in
heaven on Earth and he did that through
the means of the Jewish Nation that's
the only Earthly government that God has
ever endorsed where there's been a
fusion of church and state now the
reason why this is important to
understand is because the Bible says
Thou shalt not kill now we know from a
moral standpoint that the the Bible says
that if you even hate your brother in
your heart you have murder yeah you've
already killed him now principally how
can the government know that you hate
your brother in your heart they can't so
the reason why it's it's it's a bad idea
for these two concepts to be fused is
because the state does not have the
ability to really insert itself into
morality from a true Bible standpoint so
anytime the the the state tries to do
that it always ends in tyranny so I hope
that makes sense yeah like like um you
know anytime that worship was forced
yeah like you see God stepping in
Shadrach Meshach and abedo you know what
I mean Bow Down worship or you're going
to get thrown in the fiery furnace and
God had to step in exactly exactly so I
know it's a lot of you know
technicalities but this is really
important to understand and again going
back with the point of History one of
the reasons why a lot of times uh
persons don't like history and I I hated
academics growing up but I history was
probably one of the subjects that I I
like the most because when you see its
parallels you see why things are
currently functioning the way they do
today is there a way to Simply explain
yeah the benefit that Constantine saw in
merging a a religious power with his
government of course I mean that that's
a very good question um we were actually
talking about not too long ago I don't
know if you all have heard of a
gentleman um name uh Nica makavelli you
ever heard of him yeah the Italian
diplomat you know in the um 16th century
so um he was very famous you know in his
book um called the prince where he uh in
his you know counsel to to politicians
he mentions that it's always very
important to appear to be
religious now the reason why he says
that it's it's it's important to appear
to be religious because a religious a
religious person tends to give off an
air of morality that you can trust the
person or whatever the case may be and
that was one of the great attractions of
Christianity because mind you up until
this time Christians had been persecuted
and tortured and all of these things
generally they're very kind and loving
and so on and so forth and because
Christianity was growing so much it
seemed very clear that it was going to
eventually to some degree dominate the
Roman Empire and so in order to
consolidate that power Constantine
thought it was a good idea you know to
fuse those realities but he wasn't a
Christian though as some people some
people think yeah yeah so that's a very
good question very good
question all right this is an AI
generated picture but I thought that
this was really powerful just really you
know getting an idea of the power and
almost as it were Majesty of what the
papacy had during the Middle Ages now
again we're talking about this Fusion of
church and state and it's you know
modern implications to today so uh on
our screen this is an historian by the
name of
neander and notice what this man said as
to the reason why the papacy um the
Roman Catholic Church believe that a
fusion of chur and state was necessary
this says there had in fact Arisen in
the church a false Theocratic Theory
originating not in the essence of the
Gospel but in the confusion of the
religious constitutions of the Old and
New Testaments now I know that may seem
confusing to some but this is
essentially saying that the papacy was
confusing the theocracy of the Old
Testament and trying to put that upon
the Christian
dispensation so we know that in Israel
there was again a fusion of church and
state God was the leader
and the papacy was trying to recreate
that
reality all right it says um in the at
the bottom here it says and which might
easily result in the formation of sacral
State subordinating the secular to
itself in a false and outward way so for
some of our listeners they may be
familiar with the concept of the Holy
Roman Empire MH so the Holy Roman Empire
was essentially the papacy was the
dominating Force then you had Germany
and France and and and Spain and
Portugal and all these states and even
though they did all their imperialism
and all these things it was the papacy
that was essentially controlling it
through its
tentacles all right again at Jones the
historian now this is very important to
to Really digest and we're going to end
on some of these some of these points
this says first a true theocracy being a
government immediately directed by God a
false theocracy is a government directed
by a man in the place of God
but a man governing in the place of God
is a pope and this is why in principle
if we know that God is calling us to do
something we see something in his word
and we choose not to do it in principle
we're acting like a pope unto ourselves
cuz the spirit of popery and all of that
it's not merely you know what we see on
face value but it's the spirit behind it
which is just merely Rebellion against
God it says a man ruling the world in
the place place of God is all that the
pope has ever claimed to be so this is
the first principle of having a
theocracy you need a pope then uh
secondly he goes on to say a false
theocracy being a professed government
of God he who sits at the head of it
sits there as the representative of God
and when he speaks or acts officially
his speech or act is that of God but to
make a man thus the representative of
God is only to clothe human passions
with divine power power and authority so
you get that I mean you can see that
looking back in the history of all the
popes and the and the you know what they
actually did exactly I mean they were
doing awful awful things throughout the
the Dark Ages and and you know it's like
interesting to say that you're acting as
God but you are just this like rotten
person in fact some of the other nations
that were around that weren't even
connected to God in any way shape or
form were like these popes don't even
deserve to live they're that dark and
evil and you know this is not as a means
to arbitrarily bash especially our
Catholic friends or whatever they may
have you this is just the objective
history especially of Western Europe now
a lot of this history used to be taught
in schools you know especially you know
in England and obviously a lot of the
pilgrims that's where they came from and
a lot of this understanding was infused
into public education in the United
States but almost today you can go
through you know middle school high
school even college and never he about
the reality of these things but it's my
understanding through like Catholic
Catholic interpretation of the Bible is
that God himself is the one who
instituted this representative Peter
being the first so if you go back to the
previous slide uh it's saying that okay
this sentence here but a man Gover
governing in the place of God is a pope
but what if God placed that man to
govern yeah what would you say to that
argument it's it it's a very very good
uh question and usually what is said
well not usually but what is said is
that Peter was the first pope now again
when you read in context you know Jesus
said that the gates of hell would not
Prevail you know against and that Upon
This Rock I will build my church now
even principally we know that the first
you know instance of a rock in a
spiritual context in the Bible is
referring to Jesus and then on top of it
you know Christ said that the gates of
hell would not Prevail but the gates of
hell did Prevail against Peter when he
denied Christ With cursing and swearing
m so if there was an apostle whom uh
Christ would have built the church upon
it definitely would not have been Peter
because of those said reasons but then
again why would the great God Of Heaven
rest the salvation of humanity upon a
sinful airing mortal logically
intellectually spiritually just doesn't
make much sense so we can't make a
comparison here because God gave us a
type of church and state through the
Jews in the way that he had in heaven
and he'd like to replicate on Earth but
in the sense of having having a
representative that the two scenarios
shouldn't compare like he he wouldn't do
that or he hasn't no it's a very good
question because again the Bible is very
clear on these points and this is why
especially you know to our audience we
know that the Bible has the solutions
and the answers to all our questions and
Jesus was very clear that his
representative in John chapter 16 is the
holy spirit so if there really is a pope
on Earth it's the Holy Spirit the third
person of the godhead amen amen so yeah
it's a very good question very good
question
all right so uh continuing so we see the
first point is a pope and then the
second point is the fact of
infallibility so that you're never wrong
so again now and I know that this may be
very
startling certainly to some of our
Catholic uh listeners but most people
don't understand that part of the reason
why Catholic sex abuse in the in
pedophilia with you know little boys and
girls is so prevalent the reason why
it's covered up so much is because again
according to Catholic Canan law the
priest is literally Christ in the flesh
now just thinking logically can Christ
sin he can't so in that Catholic
theology mind even though the priest is
doing this because he's Christ it's not
really sin serious they believe the
priest is Christ in the flesh literally
I did not know that wow it it it's so
insane and we we could have put the
quotation up where um one of the uh uh
Catholic Church fathers during the
Middle Ages literally went on record as
to say that the priest is the creator of
his creator oh wow verbatim oh wow that
when the Catholic priest has the wafer
in his hand that he's literally
recreating the Divine Son of God yeah so
that's the Eucharist the Eucharist
exactly and that is basically something
that they believe that once they eat
that yeah they are literally taking
internal I understood that but to say
that priest is Christ himself yeah at
all times yes that's yeah wow now the
creator of the Creator is more than
that putting him like above
yeah okay go ahead W it it's a crazy
concept but again the the Bible makes it
very clear that this ideology didn't
originate with the papacy it originated
with Satan right and so you know his
ideology is always going to infuse
itself into these you know these Earthly
systems all right so third it says and
we're coming down to a to a close it
says third God is the moral Governor his
government at the B at the top is a
moral one so it talks about um so
actually let's just skip to the bottom
it says first the pope then the
infallibility of the pope then the
Inquisition to make his infallible
Authority effective so you see that line
of thinking so first you have the pope
then he's infallible and the only way to
enforce his popedom and infallibility is
to having Inquisition
that enforces his power so this is why
the Inquisition was so prevalent during
the Middle Ages yes and from their
perspective for the purpose of what for
the purpose of unity not even crushing
out heresy it's for the purpose of
unity and so um it's very interesting
Lord Acton um he's famous for the quote
that power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely even though he was
Roman Catholic he talks about that the
purpose of the Inquisition was not for
the purpose of crushing out heresy but
merely to establish Unity amongst the
people so even if you didn't believe in
a certain point of Catholic Doctrine as
long as you confessed it with your mouth
that was enough and it was through fear
and control which is complete opposite
of God's government exactly yeah so as
we're talking about church and state
this is the foundation that the world
has when we think about the fusion of
church and state but most people don't
understand that this is where this
Earthly understanding always leads to is
the persecution of those that don't go
along with the established power
structure mhm which is basically uh
where we believe we're actually heading
towards exactly exactly we're going to
repeat it if we don't understand it and
and the scary thing about it is
certainly here in the United States you
know and certainly maybe for some of our
listeners that are in countries that
don't have as much power as the United
States but in the United States we have
all of the trappings to make this a
reality again even from a military
standpoint I mean when you have such a
large military budget you have so much
weapons and and allies around the world
I mean we're funding NATO and all of
these things it can be very easy for us
to enforce what we want because we can
literally just nuke your country right
right my kids had questions about that
um the other day I was driving home from
from picking them up from somewhere and
they were like you know do do we have
nuclear bombs and I was like of course
we probably do and they're like does
everybody have that ability and I said
Noe we' pretty much made sure that they
don't and it's so sad you know and I
know that we're closing but you know the
United States is the still the only
country to ever drop a nuclear you know
weapon right you know yeah yeah it is
true so so what do you think about what
we're what we're seeing Yeah in our
current state right now you know a lot
of these um um conversations that are
centering on politics right now I mean
they are literally um starting to bring
religion back into the conversation what
do you think about that it's it's great
to want to bring back a semblance of
morality you know and the thing about it
is uh anything that works for the obl of
humanity um should be praised um it's
like for instance I'm pretty sure you
all familiar with Malcolm X the the
general so Malcolm X was not a godf
Fring Christian he was a Muslim now we
know from a Bible standpoint you know
Islam is a false religion um you know
even though they there's wonderful
people there I have family you know that
that are Muslim but what um Islam was
able to do for him you know in the
reform in of his life he was a you know
criminal and all those things and he was
able to you know you know reform from
that that should be praised um but at
the same time the what makes it so
different as far as the religion of of
God is that it's not
forced and human nature loves to
force and in order for somebody to be
truly trained from a Bible standpoint
they have to voluntarily want the change
you know this is why everybody's not
going to heaven not because God doesn't
want to save everybody is because many
persons will make the decision I don't
want to make the sacrifice necessary in
order to change so especially for those
persons talking about bringing you know
religion and all those things back you
know into the state if we're serious
about this certainly those of us that
are Christians we need to get on our
knees we need to pray for genuine
spiritual Revival and we need to set our
houses in order this is the primary
thing because a lot of times you'll find
out even in the news so many of these
you know um leaders of you know
religious you know Liberty and and and
um you know encouraging morality like
you'll find out six months later they're
cheating on their wives you know they're
doing all of these nefarious you know
things and so it's like it's like do
what I say but don't like do what I do
behind closed doors so it's like is it
really morality that you want or a
semblance of it that it that is enough
in order to keep away a lot of the big
sins or whatever you know very true very
true we hope you guys were blessed by
today's conversation we want to know
what you think though um is it a good
thing that we're starting to add
religion back into society or that
people are making a call for that or do
you know the history Samuel where can we
find some more um information on this
kind of a topic yes um the big one of
the biggest things I would say is the
importance of uh reading um reading is
going to be a very big thing when it
comes to that you know there's a book
you know one of the authors that we put
up at Jones uh he has a book called the
rights of the people a very very
powerful volume which goes over the
influence of church and state and the
things that we should understand
especially as United States citizens
because again I I'm not you know trying
to you know say anything salacious or
anything but what the founding fathers
of this country revolted from um Britain
for um if they were alive today you know
the revolution would have been engaged
in a long time ago um but again this is
as a result of a lot of people not
understanding the rights uh that they
have and not just as US citizens but
just as people you know in general so
that that's a very good volume as well
and then I would honestly say opening up
the word of God Amen because the word of
God it is the book of religious liberty
you know it's the book of Health it's
the book of you know how to have a good
family it's the book of everything so
you know that's that's really one of the
biggest things I would say awesome yeah
we'll leave a uh a link to his YouTube
page below and you've got a lot of like
awesome Evangelistic serieses that
you've done he works with his wife his
wife does cooking um healthful living
and uh they're actually doing a little
series around a church around here right
now so uh thank you for coming by and
blessing us indeed indeed like this
video share it with somebody that you
think would know or want to know about
this particular topic and uh we thank
you guys for stopping in and watching
our ministry uh if you'd like to support
Little Light Studios you can go to our
website little light studios. TV there's
a donate button right there but uh just
give it a thumbs up and a like that's a
huge help to us and uh we thank you guys
for
watching cre you
Jacob and he form you
is I will make him a pillar in the
temple of my God and he shall go out no
more I will ride on him the name of my
God
in the Lord and in the
power shall Str
[Music]
shall by every word I that proceeds from
the mouth of God
all right I can do
this all
[Music]
right there are conventional ways of
sharing the gospel but some may need a
different way of doing things um never
mind a way that gets the message out
with confidence
wow cool shirt what's the mean oh thank
you you know we're all made with a
unique fingerprint but we're all God's
artwork wow where'd you get
it lightwear wear your Witness
[Music]